avec nous
toujours aussi belle alors après ça vous
avait fait les anges très bien oui voilà
vous sortez avec divion c'est fini avec
viande termine c'est fini fini terminé
après vous avez la villa des coeurs
brisés saison 2 est alors aussitôt vous
avez perdu de vue vous à retrouver dans
sept à huit sur tf1 cette semaine avec
une très belle audience puisque on a
découvert que eh bien vous faisiez des
photos de charme est sur des sites qu
car je connaissais pas sans rien
s'appelle mime ou my only fans donc
c'est des cons tout en fait il faut
payer si vous payez un peu vous voyez
pas grand chose si vous payez plus on
voit beaucoup plus alors ça dépend des
personnes c'est vrai que pour ma part
lorsque vous prenez à l'abonnement vous
pouvez recevoir des photos et des vidéos
et puis si les abonnés veulent un petit
peu plus
alors si on prend la bonne étoile
abonnements le plus cher l'abonnement
est à 24 euros par mois alors pour ce
prix là qu'est ce qu'on peut voir de
nathalie alors vous voyez des photos
sexy alors ça dépend des plaques fait
des vidéos des photos ya de tout ah bon
photos et vidéos c'est vous seul
et non je peux être accompagnés ah oui
ça s'appelle du d'accord d'accord
d'accord d'accord
du prêt nous étions considère que c'est
du porno donc oui effectivement minutes
non je dis pas venu ça bug du charme
mais si vous êtes deux bouts fait des
choses après vous pouvez faire du duo
mais ça peut être très érotique c'est
pas forcément du porno bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr bien c'est donc la
nuance avec mes profil j'entends bien et
donc vous êtes sur ce site a depuis
combien de temps alors sur annie fan ça
fait deux ans et demi ouais on pas trop
s'était démarqué mais oui alors moi j'ai
créé mon propre ma propre plate forme
d'accord ça fait un an ça fait un an et
alors vous avez déclaré dans sept à huit
bars regarder on va voir l'extrait
justement on parle d'argent à regarder
ce que vous avez dit
nathalie andréani est devenu l'une des
stars de ces plates formes
inscrite depuis deux ans elle fait
aujourd'hui entre 100 et 150 mille euros
de chiffre d'affaires par mois nathalie
à 51 ans elle passe deux heures par jour
à la salle de sports la sasp en salle en
fait parce que ça reste le corps est ce
une vitrine pour moi ça va spontanément
le travail donc je peux pas le permettre
de prendre 5 kg et de laisser aller
c'est impossible nathalie a participé à
une émission de téléréalité il ya sept
ans forte de sa popularité
elle compte aujourd'hui trois mille
abonnés qui payent pour admirer son
corps
alors là j'avoue comment on passe de 6,4
story ou votre secret était je suis je
sors avec vivian c'est ça c'est le
compagnon divion confond souvent ou pas
mais qui était un jeune garçon de ces
capteurs et comment comment est-ce qu'on
passe de 6,4 story au porno alors tout
simplement j'ai toujours eu le culte du
corps jeu très sportive a joué moi aussi
mon nom mais justement est en fait j'ai
été approché par des marques de lingerie
pour faire de la publicité où elle est
très très critiqué sur les réseaux
sociaux et à force d'être critiqué c'est
vrai que j'avais beaucoup de demandes de
la part de certains hommes qui voulant
voir un petit peu plus sûr je me suis
dit tiens je vais créer un compte
instagram que je vais faire mais je vais
faire payer l'entrée à l'époque je
faisais payer 10 euros l'entrée et
geoffrey des photos de lingerie les
choses très très sexy sauf qu'évidemment
instagram a eu vent de cette aventure
ils m'ont fermer mon compte et on m'a
parlé d'un nid fans là je suis parti sur
cette plateforme et il m'a montré une
photo avait charmé le coup venir par un
site porno ça fait mais il a lu en fait
j'ai évolué tout doucement c'est à dire
que j'ai commencé par la lingerie puis
j'ai montré mais ça je me suis montrée
nue et je suis beaucoup d'art c'est très
artistique ce cachet très jeunes ici pas
je ne juge pas j'imagine que jean michel
vous connaissiez pas on se connaît oui
on se connaît en plus oui a
personnellement bien sûr l abonnement
je connaissais même pas le site je ne
sais même pas de site non parce qu'on
les partenaires pour une opération
ensemble jaune mais jamais pourquoi dès
qu'un plan foireux tu es dedans
on
fait la loupe tous les deux magazines
après bientôt à la fille très jolie sens
d'une séance de photos et une faute
fatale il a une âme et je sais c'est
quoi
c'était encore une marque là et jackie
et michel autre vidéo hot vidéo parce
qu'en fait voir et on est obligés
maintenant d'aller plus loin parce que
je sais je suis pas du tout bien pas
acteur porno non il se trouve que un des
acteurs du monde du manga érotique
français et jacky michel lancelot
recrute aux monnaies et je viendrai
l'égérie de cette crypte aux monnaies
d'accord et du coup j'ai posé avec
nathalie pour une une du magazine gala
moi j'ai une question à poser aux
chroniqueurs sert à ça vous choque ou
pas c'est que visiblement c'est vous
avez deux enfants deux filles de 3 de 24
et 27 ans c'est ça et je crois que c'est
souvent elle qui vous film ça c'est faux
alors mes filles me prennent en photo
quand je suis sur la plage en maillot de
bain si je fais une photo par exemple
j'essaie d'aller faire des photos dans
une forêt en lingerie mais une de mes
filles me prendre en photo en aucun cas
mes fils me prennent quand je tourne des
vidéos nues où l'attendent plaisent ou
quoi que ce soit mais fine ne rentre pas
dans ce domaine alors on a extrait vous
en parle justement vire
personnes travaillent pour elles un
agent un avocat et entre autres ses deux
filles eve sa cadette de 24 ans la prend
en photo régulièrement uniquement quand
elle pose en lingerie
f ça vous gêne pas tu vas te merde ans
dans ses positions non non ça me gêne
pas c'est joli ça je trouve pas ça
vulgaire elle est couverte elle est pas
toute nue
vous n'avez pas l'impression en faisant
ça de vendre votre mère devant le corps
de wagner non non je n'avance pas c'est
seulement des photos et après elle en
fait ce que ce qu'elle veut moi j'ai une
éducation très puritaine ferait vraiment
à la corse et tout mais je sais pas
pourquoi on inculque aux gens certaines
valeurs qui sont pas forcément les
bonnes alors je sais que c'est donc
c'est pas votre fille qui vous filmer
tout ça mais forcément votre fille quand
elles vont sur des sites tels vouvoie ou
ma mère en train de faire non mes filles
avons pas sur ces sites à l on pas que
c'est elles vont sur mon instagram alors
qu'est-ce que les caf à surmonter le mal
aux forcément déjà vu ps aux curieuses
étudiants même à faire du porno des
photos regarder elle voit mes photos
sexy et elle voit j'aimerais vous dire
mieux la première fois que j'ai vendu
des photos topless on avait fait des
photos avec un photographe et c'est une
de mes filles qui m'a dit maman tu vas
sur n'importe quel site instagram et
c'était enfin pas instagram et dans les
réseaux sociaux tu vas trouver des
actrices des chanteuses pour la poitrine
à l'air oui mais cela l'horaire voyage
est-ce que ça choque quelqu'un ici
notamment parce que vous étiez dans des
missions à béja qui alors juste dans un
instant est-ce que ici et
moi ça me ça me choque pas j'ai regardé
le reportage je trouve ça très
intéressant et je vous aime beaucoup je
vous êtes très intelligente et vous
faites les choses avec beaucoup
d'intelligence et ce qui est important
quand même de savoir c'est que comme
vous l'avez dit cfi la prennent en photo
quand elle n'a pas les seins à l'air le
elle a une culotte c'est des photos
comme on voit à la spirale des
ralliements fait d'avoir fait
secretstory est aujourd'hui d'être très
triste corneau c'est quoi le lien ou pas
un problème on peut être boulangère et
puis après faire des photos sexy je vois
pas vraiment le problème et ses enfants
ne doivent pas être abonné à sa
plateforme qui ne parlent pas fermée
pour regarder les vidéos qui vont plus
loin donc moi ça me choque pas et sa
fille alors très équilibrée elle sait ce
qu'elle fait bon matin moi ce qui me
choque c'est pas forcément le fait
qu'elle vous prennent en sous vêtements
etc parce que bon ça encore ça va mais
c'est le fait que en faisant ça elle
participe un peu à vos vidéos qui sont
plus et ça veut dire qu'elle accepte
parce que si les accepte que vous soyez
en string un peu en vêtements très sexy
dans les poses un peu subjective comme
ça moi je veux dire qu'elle accepte
aussi le plus le porno les vidéos j'ai
envie non plus il faisait un peu avec
des sexes james horwill
oui sextoys et c'est bon j'ai 24 ans
j'ai le même âge que 26 bah moi ma mère
c'est le drs je pense que ça me
choquerait un peu et peut-être que en
maillot de bain bon ça va c'est ça passe
mais alors les vidéos avec deux désolait
un
peu car elles ont évolué avec moi c'est
à dire que je serais arrivé du jour à
leur nature curieuse forcément quelque
chose il s'appelle normalement on le
ferait tout ce nom tire avoir
l'amour avec un homme jamais de la vie
n'ont
pas pardonné moi je serai que vous allez
rippert intelligente et très structurée
dans votre propos est dans votre
entreprise mais c'est vrai que moi ça me
choque un peu parce que bon vous êtes en
dessous mais il ya dessous les dessous
c'est quand même des dessous très coquin
le sac à main on dirait un martinet
enfin c'est un truc voilà c'est dit oh
pardon et c'est vrai que moi je suis
papa aussi je vous vois avec votre fille
qui vous prend en photo est-ce que vous
avez pas un peu l'impression
d'encourager une forme d'argent facile
liés aux corps et aux éau et au charme
de vendre ses charmes que vous fassiez
ce choix c'est une chose mais que votre
fille participe même un tout petit peu
moi ça me choque un petit peu je voulais
avoir un vétéran comme on imagine tous
le rapport à nos enfants et nos parents
oui puis j'ai appelé mes parents ont
carrément mais là on est dans un monde
particulier ces filles là connaissent
depuis longtemps elles ont vu dans
secret story elles savent que leur maman
est les influences eux on peut pas
comparer on a tous envie de comparer que
nos parents ou nos influences s'épanouit
et
quand même
son métier ne sache pas mes fiches tiens
à vous dire une chose le choc de choc vu
mes filles elles sont là elles sont
présentes elles sont très intelligents
structuré en aucun cas elles ont envie
de faire ça ça les intéresse absolument
pas seriez d'accord être canon
maintenant si elles ont envie de le
faire et le fond il faut aménager vous
comprenez qu'il est pour les gens qui
regardent c'est de se dire que
finalement pas plutôt de travailler à
rejeter le vieux con me dire ça mais sur
vos gagné 5,58 euros par mois bon bah un
sextoy bayonne lifan est un garçon un
peu sympa déjà dans un premier temps je
gagne d'argent comme ça parce que je
suis connue fouet ruinettes et à
l'inconnu qui vient à kiss mais sur une
plateforme faut pas rêver les filles
n'auront pas ces sommes là ça donc comme
l'affluence en général d'ailleurs depuis
vous dirais-je la villa des coeurs
brisés et derrière et sur mam libanais
gagner 5000 euros par mois vous le
verriez pas de problème mais pour mes
filles elles font ce qu'elles veulent
elles pensent qu'elles veulent de son
corps moi je j'ai rien à dire dans leur
vie personnelle du moment tu fais tu
fais un téléchargement résume ce que tu
fais non j'ai pas de là vous avez
accompagné non chérie je sais ce que je
fais ma vie de puylaurens à
oued un jeu
basique et puis jacky aussi parce que
jacky elle vous regarde autre question
est intéressant de faire diversion je
suis célibataire depuis trois ans parce
que il ya des hommes qui ne supporte pas
ce genre d'actifs dont on peut le
comprendre
c'est la question que j'avais posé
derrière on m'a déjà fait on m'a dit
regarde moi je me mettre en couple avec
toi mais tu vas rythme d'activité bien
sûr alors moi je pense que nathalie fesf
et son métier très professionnellement
je pense qu'elle a étudié toutes les
toutes les astuces en marche à gauche et
a défié ses filles je pense que ses
filles sont conscientes que la mère ce
qu'elle fait c'est pour un but lucratif
de leurs plans du plaisir à d'autres et
arte c'est ce qu'il ya d'exceptionnel
c'est continuera d'exister parce qu'à
des clients fidèles
est-ce que même elle appelle les cartes
de fidélité caveau subway comment ça je
ne suis pas je rentre un peu c'est mon
idole artimon entreprises qui à le dire
et son actionnaire dans mon entreprise
beau temps dans tout le jour où j'arrête
et une partie de leur argent qui leur
fera aussi reverser et c'est ça aussi
pour mes enfants
je centre est
je suis j'ai pas vu secretstory non
non mais si je l'avais vu peut-être pour
résoudre est autrement mais là ça
bouchonnait la c1 me choque un peu c'est
à dire on voit qu'à une complicité entre
elle et ses enfants way est un portail
mais moi déjà je pense pas me balader à
poil devant ma fille
sachant qu'avec un sextoy encore
je comprends l'idée est là c'est vrai
que j'ai pas du tout imaginé ça non mais
charmante je vois bien que oui elle fait
les choses artistiquement mais pour moi
ça a du porno et je sais que je
demanderai jamais à ma fille m'aime de
me prendre une photo normale ce qu'on
voit presque je suis un peu d'accord mon
chapeau au cdh écolo si j'avais su là je
vous fait pas prendre en photo par aux
deux filles par exemple non mais après
je te comprends que c'est parce que
maintenant le nouveau truc ajustable
nouveau toute maintenance est découpée
du porno 10 et artistique pour moi oui
on apprendra terminé
à g quand je vous ai posé des questions
avant l'émission par téléphone on s'est
parlé un petit peu d'accord et vous
m'avez dit que que ce que vous faisiez
permettez à ce qu'il y ait moins
d'hommes dans la rue par exemple qui
vous m'avez dit j'utilise le terme un ce
trip hop en pleine rue et c est que vous
contribuez du coup à ce que les lois
auxquelles auraient vous habitez c'est
ça existe est ce que vous pensez du coup
vous êtes utile ben moi je sens et la
route alors je vais dire jeu mais je
porte je pense que toutes les tds mois
les travailleurs du sexe qui font ça
elles sont très utiles à la société faut
vraiment pas d'émigrer dénigrer ceux de
travailler ce métier parce que c'est
denis profession c'est un métier de
faire ça quand on dit c'est de l'argent
facile je travaille 15 heures par jour
c'est pas deux heures par jour je fais
des photos et où il ya vraiment une
grosse course ou
de sport dont
une dernière fois
question si la photo alors nous on n'a
pas pu mettre les photos jacques des
raisons une photo on a des photos ou pas
des photos sexy ou pas finir tu ne peux
pas non là alors de grande écoute on à
droite oui juste c'est important quand
même 2 n'était pas ce qu'elle a dit dans
le reportage qu'elle n'encourage pas les
jeunes à le faire c'est là où elle est
très responsable dans le reportage elle
précise qu'elle n'encourage personne
n'avait voulu vous était venu tout est
devenu très habile mais quand on fait
quelque chose et qu'on le montre pas
dire je le fais je n'encourage pas
freddy au vallon lui va lui poser les
mêmes questions qu'on pose à nathalie
non mais lui l'a jamais dit qui
l'encouragé pas lui dis-je fait du porno
j'adore ça mais comme c'est un homme on
va pas se poser autant de questions qui
nous dit on la garde de la misogynie je
trouve qu'il a raison oui
je voulais savoir si nathalie me faisais
ça parce que pour l'argent si vous aimez
ça ou vous avez dit dans une autre
interview vous faisiez ça aussi pour se
parler pour les hommes avec tout ça les
aide
en leur disant bonjour le matin voir le
choix est large mais je fais ça vraiment
pour plusieurs raisons alors la première
évidemment c'est l'argent oui j'ai un
petit peu chaque personne qui va
travailler le matin c'est pour de
l'argent pourquoi elle a fait ça
gratuitement ouais mais vous aimez
rabineau veille alors elle y prend du
plaisir dans la journée des abonnés
fidèles depuis trois ans avec qui je
suis devenu ami il ya un vrai contact on
fait du social c'est vraiment du social
et je te rends service à la société
j'avais bien si vous avez un message
merci beaucoup nathalie
[Applaudissements]